yeah buddy how many happen how's it goin
brevis my name is PewDiePie welcome back
to sum up Atlas let's play shall we oh
my god oh my god ice oh hey fancy
meeting you here great times yes damn
yeah the base frame nice Hank's tell me
it's your ass isn't it okay bend over
yes
come here I'm not
thank you you can tell me anything but
you're a t-rex that's impossible but not
a facebook [ __ ] III know I can help you
out with that you know all right now
you're just repeating yourself Gandil
I can't go there hi oh good berries I
can't pick it up there we go
berries at the Mart oh hi Oh God if
you're gonna go on all the way long JC
is he following me for [ __ ] sake shut
up you've won miniaturize ask it's not
weird yo [ __ ] Oh God all right you know
what going there go in there now shut
the [ __ ] up god damn annoying [ __ ] he
can't open the door either oh yeah all
that keys you can goddamn it am I
supposed to go back now the cassandra'
don't really want to um where are we
pretty cool place
I recognize this we've been here for
sure now where's the head the cuffs I
don't remember [ __ ] my sense oh [ __ ]
we're here you can't fight me i am
swedish swedish people look up and they
will miss me and there will be like 'we
need a guy god and then they will be
like oh i don't really know and then i
probably don't care in the long run but
hey what are you gonna do about it don't
touch my feet all right time to go home
time to go home jaehun tree road to the
place where I belong
what's that hello oh that's an infirmary
a great place great place to be no David
I'm a pod
oh you beardy son-of-a-bitch do you not
a teleport I like getting [ __ ] for a
beard
no sorry nope can hats
oh no don't burn me bro okay
Oh
oh that hurts ouch ouch ouch ouch I
guess we'll have it raw that it makes
sense I try to make drugs sometimes and
I think oh god damn one cook at a time
baby
this place is fantastic
love it love love love it
blah blah blah everyone this looks like
a dead end
see sometimes I can reload but sometimes
I can't I don't that kind of sucks
Oh accent how nice great I'm just gonna
cut gosh darn it - Danny best hope
oh there's it's so good that there's
three of them
sorry six of them it was like you know
what if I'm gonna have a chapel the
better damn be six paintings identical
alright alright I'm not gonna be a
goddamn P that's probably how you went
oh hello documents when the mine is
gonna can't go on documents God in the
family father be from alright if you
wanted palace envy that you can go right
ahead then Sarah
oh I can't reload because I don't have
any [ __ ] batteries and there's a
[ __ ] ladder oh my god I just facepalm
by myself that's not good
alright I wish there was an achievement
in this game for like zooming in and all
their asses
god damn calm down alright progress
[ __ ] doing great press
high-five yeah best sound effects ever
oh yeah fire I'm great climber I wish my
mom saw this she always said I could
have climb I know that this is all a
dream coming true
just don't fall that it's not that oh
god not now
Oh God for [ __ ] sake nothing hi
can you get one second breaking this
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god damn it all this
just became Mirror's Edge 20 you
oh hello I'll just go in here thank you
very much see you later
great times best times oh is that my
shadow brick break it down to the box
girl sorry
running very low batteries let's go into
the dark and creepy hellhole let's be
honest that's probably where they want
you to go why should Dix oh hello
that's it batteries when the mind is
gone you can't go on now we can realize
genius so genius the worst part when I
find out something later it's light I
know that you brought something tearing
your hair over the fact that I can't see
it and I'm not gonna read that [ __ ] in
the college sir oh god is he still
around
give me a goddamn break I'm not tasty
I probably tastes like [ __ ] oh god it's
add that self-absorbed guy again if I've
gotta be in this hallway they got a baby
get it again game be quick
everyone everyone else is escaping but
us that's that's great times
lalalalalalala you can come in here
[ __ ] what you gonna do what you gonna
do about it what you gonna do what
you're gonna do I'm gonna get out of
here
I could have gone a little better but
what do you know
oh [ __ ] you can't you can't just claim
it like that I ain't belong to her but
yeah okay alright alright that's alright
that's alright on my bounce [ __ ] Papa
back rocks what you're gonna do about
this box what you gonna do about it
[ __ ] what you gonna do about that
bouncer what you gonna do buddy [ __ ]
alright I'm a box I'm a box I promise
yes
Darren great I can't
yeah damn it she tricked me that's me
you're naked and ugly no [ __ ] done
Hey
where am i this is it that's a gorgeous
game this is very pretty
okay oh god I can't handle this [ __ ] job
I can't I can't
it's so overwhelming playing this game
and it's undescribable Angie's parents
okay
oh okay here got a document to
everything I guess something like in the
keyboard is like
Wow it's like I have to do everything
alright alright alright it's coming up
the main valve
why should I say be him you might as
well [ __ ] kill me for all I know
hello this is the main valve thing
seriously
[ __ ] they're really not nice where is
it fun sake I lost the ability to ten
anything wouldn't he be dead by now
anyway like oh god there's a lot of room
said means a lot of places to hide and
that means a lot of [ __ ] are gonna
come out for us
am i right am i right ladies am i right
sorry
you have no idea what I'm talking my
dear very good fun what men divorce on
saw Danny cute Jenner is a venti pick
Danny Bob Lang it's no penny
he is just after me isn't he what did I
ever do
I don't know what I've been being nice
person that's what I did
he's gonna come here isn't he nope now
today [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
see you later alligator hater skater
[ __ ] did you literally just [ __ ]
open the door but he's too [ __ ] smart
oh god it really starts in the [ __ ]
man ha ha ha
Oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna feed you
brought you're gonna have to feed
yourself
I wish I about it Oh God Oh God
nothing not me why do you get that idea
why did you get that idea why did you
later alligator skater hater Oh God oh
my god there it is
thanks Jesus oh oh
oh my god why you doing I tell me why
you do that to me Timmy
I thought we were cool I thought we were
cool that's that's okay toilet I'm all
out of [ __ ] a lot of shits can give no
[ __ ] getting get nobody no shits go in
this place has a lot of time - girl yes
I'm suspecting a jump-scare this game is
not that nice hello hot out great great
great great he's not here and what do we
do we look at the goats I think their
horses but who cares all right they
really struck took down the batteries in
this one that's a nice sock on the bunny
thing y'all cuddle up on it that one
hand there my hand what was that oh god
oh god what was that what was that did
someone shoot no so this is where the
girls come from good notice all right
let me click that [ __ ]
I can't do anything about it it looks
like true [ __ ] off all right
sorry night looks like you're pretty
[ __ ] anyway to be honest
all right let's not get choked on that
gas
great times we'd hit it perfect
hello any gas in here no [ __ ] way I'm
so [ __ ] tired of him hope you enjoy
watching maybe like if you did breast
it helps me out a lot it's been a pretty
epic series so far I hope you're
enjoying it and I'll see you tomorrow
love your breasts